79% of America's millionaires inherited
precisely zero 5% of America's
millionaires inherited a very small
amount like $5,000 from Grandmother but
not enough to make them mathematically a
millionaire it was an insignificant
small amount but they did technically
get an
inheritance another 5% inherited money
that was substantial after they were
already millionaires so did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
but enhanced their wealth after they
were already millionaires so let me help
you with that 790 five small five after
79 plus 5 plus 5 is
89% that's nine out of
10 of the current approximately 15
million millionaires in North America
became millionaires not because of
inherited money